we all go to doctors and we do so with
trust and blind faith that the tests
they are ordering and the medications
they're prescribing are based upon
evidence evidence that's designed to
help us however the reality is that that
hasn't always been the case for everyone
what if I told you that the medical
science discovered over the past century
has been based on only half the
population I'm an emergency medicine
doctor I was trained to be prepared in a
medical emergency it's about saving
lives how cool is that okay there's a
lot of runny noses and stubbed toes but
no matter who walks through the door to
the ER we order the same tests we
prescribe the same medication without
ever thinking about the sex or gender of
our patients why would we we were never
taught that there were any differences
between men and women a recent
Government Accountability study revealed
that 80% of the drugs withdrawn from the
market are due to side effects on women
so let's think about that for a minute
why are we discovering side effects on
women only after a drug has been
released to the market do you know that
it takes years for a drug to go from an
idea to being tested on cells in a
laboratory to animal studies to then
clinical trials on humans finally to go
through a regulatory approval process to
be available for your doctor to
prescribe to you not to mention the
millions and billions of dollars of
funding it takes to go through that
process so why are we discovering
unacceptable side-effects on half the
population
after that has gone through what's
happening well it turns out that those
cells used in that laboratory their male
cells and the animals used in the animal
studies were male animals and the
clinical trials have been performed
almost exclusively on men how is it that
the male model became our framework for
medical research let's look at an
example that has been popularized in the
media and it has to do with the sleep
aid ambien ambien was released on the
market over 20 years ago and since then
hundreds of millions of prescriptions
have been written primarily to women
because women suffer more sleep
disorders than men but just this past
year the Food and Drug Administration
recommended cutting the dose in half for
women only because they just realized
that women metabolize the drug at a
slower rate than men causing them to
wake up in the morning with more of the
active drug in their system and then
their drowsy and they're getting behind
the wheel of the car and they're at risk
for motor vehicle accidents you know and
I can't help but think as an emergency
physician how many of my patients that
I've cared for over the years that were
involved in a motor vehicle accident
possibly could have been prevented if
this type of analysis was performed and
acted upon 20 years ago when this drug
was first released how many other things
need to be analyzed by gender what else
are we missing World War two changed a
lot of things and one of them was this
need to protect people from becoming
victims of medical research without
informed consent
so some much-needed guidelines and rules
were set into place and part of that was
this desire to protect women of
childbearing age from entering into any
medical research studies
it was fear what if something happened
to the fetus during this study who would
be responsible and so the scientists at
this time actually thought this was a
blessing in disguise because let's face
it men's bodies are pretty homogeneous
they don't have the constantly
fluctuating levels of hormones that
could disrupt clean data they could get
if they had only men it was easier it
was cheaper
not to mention at this time there was a
general assumption that men and women
were alike in every way apart from their
reproductive organs and sex hormones so
it was decided medical research was
performed on men and the results were
later applied to women what did this do
to the notion of women's health women's
health became synonymous with
reproduction breasts ovaries uterus
pregnancy it's this term we now refer to
as bikini medicine and this stayed this
way until about the 1980s when this
concept was challenged by the medical
community and by the public health
policy makers when they realized that by
excluding women from all medical
research studies we actually did them a
disservice and that apart from
reproductive issues virtually nothing
was known about the unique needs of the
female patient since that time an
overwhelming amount of evidence has come
to light that shows us just how
different men and women are in every way
you know we have this saying in medicine
children are not just little adults and
we say that to remind ourselves that
children actually have a different
physiology than normal adults and it's
because of this that the medical
specialty of Pediatrics came to light
and we now conduct research on children
in order to improve their lives and I
know the same thing can be said about
women women are not just men with boobs
and tubes but that they have their own
anatomy and physiology that deserves to
be studied with the same intensity let's
take the cardiovascular system for
example this area and medicine has done
the most to try to figure out why it
seems men and women have completely
different heart attacks heart disease is
the number one killer for both men and
women but more women die within the
first year of having a heart attack than
men men will complain of crushing chest
pain an elephant is sitting on their
chest and we call this typical women
have chest pain too but more women than
men will complain of just not feeling
right can't seem to get enough air in
just so tired lately and for some reason
we call this atypical even though I as I
mentioned women do make up half the
population and so what are some of the
evidence to help explain some of these
differences if we look at the anatomy
the blood vessels that surround the
heart are smaller in women compared to
men and the way that those blood vessels
develop disease is different in women
compared to men and the tests that we
use to determine if someone's at risk
for heart
well they were initially designed and
tested and perfected in men and so
aren't as good at determining that in
women and then if we think about the
medications common medications that we
use like aspirin we give aspirin to
healthy men to help prevent them from
having a heart attack but do you know
that if you give aspirin to a healthy
woman it's actually harmful what this is
doing is merely telling us that we are
scratching the surface emergency
medicine is a fast-paced business
how many life-saving areas of medicine
like cancer and stroke are there
important differences between men and
women that we could be utilizing or even
why is it that some people get those
runny noses more than others or why the
pain medication that we give to those
stubbed toes work in some and not in
others the Institute of Medicine has
said every cell has a sex what does this
mean sex is DNA gender is how someone
presents themselves in society and these
two may not always match up as we can
see with our transgendered population
but it's important to realize that from
the moment of conception every cell in
our bodies skin hair heart and lungs
contain our own unique DNA and that DNA
contains the chromosomes that determine
whether we become male or female man a
woman it used to be thought that those
sex-determining chromosomes pictured
here XY if you're male xx if you're
female merely determined whether you
would be born with ovaries or testes
it was the sex hormones that those
organs produced or what was responsible
for the differences we see in the
opposite sex but we now know that that
theory was wrong or it's at least a
little incomplete and thankfully
scientists like dr. page from the
Whitehead Institute who works on the y
chromosome and dr. yang from UCLA they
have found evidence that tells us that
those sex-determining chromosomes that
are in every cell in our bodies continue
to remain active for our entire lives
and could be what's responsible for the
differences we see in the dosing of
drugs or why there are differences
between men and women and the
susceptibility and severity of diseases
this new knowledge is the game-changer
and it's up to those scientists that
continue to find that evidence but it's
up to the clinicians to start
translating this data at the bedside
today right now and to help do this I'm
a co-founder of a national organization
called sex and gender women's health
collaborative and we collect all of this
data so that it's available for teaching
and for patient care
and we're working to bring together the
medical educators to the table that's a
big job it's changing the way medical
training has been done since its
inception but I believe in them I know
they're gonna see the value of
incorporating the gender lens into the
current curriculum it's about training
the future health care providers
correctly and regionally I'm a
co-creator of a division within the
Department of Emergency Medicine here at
Brown University
called sex and gender and emergency
medicine and we conduct the research to
determine the differences between men
and women in emergent conditions like
heart disease and stroke and sepsis and
substance abuse but we also believe that
education is paramount we've created a
360 degree model of education we have
programs for the doctors for the nurses
for the students and for the patients
because this cannot just be left up to
the healthcare leaders we all have a
role in making a difference but I must
warn you this is not easy in fact it's
hard it's essentially changing the way
we think about medicine and health and
research it's changing our relationship
to the healthcare system but there's no
going back we now know just enough to
know that we weren't doing it right
Martin Luther King jr. has said change
does not roll in on the wheels of
inevitability but comes through
continuous struggle and the first step
towards changes awareness this is not
just about improving medical care for
women this is about personalized
individualized health care for everyone
this awareness has the power to
transform medical care for men and women
and from now on I want you to ask your
doctors whether the treatments you're
receiving are specific to your sex and
gender they may not know the answer yet
but the conversation has begun and
together we can all learn remember from
me and my colleagues in this field
your sex and gender matter thank you